[موسيقى]
لكنني هنا اليوم لأنني أعتقد
أن منتجات facebook تضر بالأطفال تثير
الانقسام وتضعف ديمقراطيتنا
[موسيقى]
تعرف قيادة الشركة كيف
تجعل Facebook و instagram أكثر أمانًا ولكنها
فازت  لن يقوموا بإجراء التغييرات اللازمة
لأنهم وضعوا أرباحهم الفلكية
قبل
الحاجة إلى اتخاذ إجراء في الكونجرس ،
ولن يحلوا هذه الأزمة بدون
مساعدتك
[موسيقى]
لذا يريد Facebook أن تصدق أن
المشكلات التي نتحدث عنها هي
يريدون منك أن تؤمن بخيارات خاطئة غير قابلة للحل
ويريدون منك أن تصدق أنه يجب عليك
الاختيار بين فيسبوك مليء
بالمحتوى المثير للانقسام والمتطرف أو فقدان
واحدة من أهم القيم التي
تأسست عليها بلادنا على أساس
حرية التعبير
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
أنت